welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
boss and the mcu mutants have arrived
with kamala khan established as the
first mutant that we know about in the
616 mcu in the miss marvel finale kamala
there's something different
in your genes like a mutation
whatever it is it's just gonna be
another label yeah just a label good
luck with that kid you got the 90s x-men
animated themed needle drop stamp of
approval beyond the matter of this being
a retcon from kamala khan being an
inhuman in the comics this finally shows
to us marvel studios hand when it comes
to their long planned mutant rollout in
the mcu so what does kamala being a
mutant mean for future marvel
introductions in the mcu if kamala can
have a mutant gene who else does how
does this all work also how does bruno
know all this like is there a section on
the caltech application requiring
genetic profiles of your crushes but i
needed to know for science and this
video was sponsored by brain shadow
legends we'll give you some more
information on them in a moment bringing
in the mutants is something marvel
studios has been able to do since disney
acquired the film rights to the x-men
from box in 2018 and kevin feige's tz
announcement back at comic con 2019.
there's no time left to talk about
mutants
[Applause]
and notice how feige said mutants there
not x-men meaning that they always plan
for something more organic for the
genesis of mutants in this universe as
opposed to a major multiversal crossover
of major stars from the x-men fox
franchise it's not gonna be so much
about people who are aligned with the
x-men but rather the personal stories of
people who just happen to have that
genetic profile so kamala khan actually
makes the third mutant tease in marvel
phase four after the evan peters fake
out as pietro aka ralph boner in one
division and patrick stewart charles
xavier cameo and multiverse of madness
but really only the second to receive
the 90s x-men riffs so they're the only
ones that matter though i have theorized
that ralph could return in wonderban so
don't count him out charles xavier's
cameo represented one mutant path that
we've long theorized multiversal
crossover in this planet beloved actors
who we already know who played mutants
in the past to x-men titles could just
join the mcu via some incursion like
when reed richards babbled on about
incursions and multiverse of madness as
a whole seemed to be setting up the
avengers secret wars crossover event it
seemed at least possible that known
x-men stars from universe 838 and beyond
could be established as the x-men in the
616 universe alongside the other
avengers of course multiverse of madness
proved that those cameos were really
just added to the movie as fanservicey
lives to the cosmic slaughter and now
kamala khan's mutant designation implies
a different path that we've talked about
a more grassroots genetic approach that
the mcu could just establish that the
mutant gene already exists in a number
of individuals throughout the 616
universe but was simply dormant until
now or just unseen in the storylines we
focused on until this point and in this
path the famous mutant characters we
know would likely be recast as mcu
variants which we have endlessly fan
cast on this channel now if you've
watched our videos before you probably
already know how much we love raid it's
got global pvp massive pve boss battles
and over 600 champions that you can
choose from but today we're going to
talk about one of those badass bosses
you get to fight because they are my
favorite part of the game in today's
boss i'm going to gush about bombo the
dreadhorn he is a lava rhino who loves
bombs it's like somebody reached into
the part of my brain labeled awesome
things yanked bombed a dreadhorn into
existence then put him into this game so
i get to feel even more awesome by
beating him up using his own bombs
bommie bombo the bomb ass bomb rhino yes
please raid never gets old for me
because there is always something new to
do in this month beyond adding five new
champions to choose from and overhauling
the champion vault raids running a ton
of summer splash events that means new
skins for everyone's favorite hammer
swinging dwarf trying to get mallet also
you can get deliana a brand new champion
from the high elves faction all you
gotta do is log on and play raid for
seven days between now and july 28th if
you're a new player use promo code my
deliana and you'll also get 50 xp brews
so that you can get deliana up to max
level and start kicking butt right away
there's never been a better time to get
started with raid and if you click the
link in the description or use our qr
code you can get 30 worth of unique
bonuses this means a rector draft that's
a free epic champion 200 000 silver one
energy refill one xp boost and one
ancient shard so that you can summon
awesome champions as soon as you get in
game all of these treasures will be
waiting for you right here just head to
your inbox once you get in and you'll be
ready to raid but for now marvel studios
seems to be walking both paths because
ryan reynolds deadpool is confirmed to
join the mcu playing the same version of
himself we think from his 2016 film and
2018 film which were more linked to the
fox x-men continuity and that would
suggest that he's going to join the mcu
as a result of some kind of incursion
event like what reid warned about or
maybe in secret wars or on the other
side of secret wars deadpool's always
been an interesting one because he's
always been kind of a bugs bunny meta
figure now to clarify something about
how multiversal variants work at least
in the eyes of the mcu brass marvel
producer richie palmer explained that
the mcu has some kind of varying logic
for whether multiversal variants are
played by the same actor or by different
ones suggesting characters like doctor
strange and juana maximoff are really
more fixed egocentric souls in which all
of their variants look the same whereas
characters like loki are by their nature
agents of chaos who shape-shift and take
alternate forms thus loki's variants
looking like tom hiddleston in some
instances but also like other actors and
other animals characters like peter
parker are different actors because the
early 2000s comics established
multiversal spider-man as really a
diverse spectrum of variants that the
whole journey of peter parker is to meet
spider-man who look nothing like him but
getting back to kamala khan being a
mutant marvel now firmly plants a flag
in the option to activate mutants
genetically within their population
setting up a kind of guessing game for
fans in which like with the scrolls any
enhanced individual we meet or already
know may have their powers as a result
of a genetic precondition called the
mutant gene or the x gene ms marvel's
head writer confirmed that making kamala
a mutant wasn't always the plan but they
introduced it as a way to explain why
only kamala not anyone in her family
descending from the north dimension only
kamala would get powers when putting on
that bengal they needed to make her
specifically different in some way and
you can read about how this decision led
to a humorous email exchange between
iman vilani and kevin feige now we're
still left a little fuzzy on why kamala
needs to be a mutant however like in
avoiding the inhuman terror genesis
backstory the disney plus series tried
to explain kamala's powers with three
fantastical sources hard light from the
nor dimension alien technology of the
bengal and now kamala's unique mutant
gene remember in the marvel comics the
mutant gene is something all mutants are
born with and activates at a young age
most of the time through puberty or
through trauma in some cases uh weird
experimentation or energy exposure but
in the mcu so far organic mutants
require three components a mutant gene a
source unique to that person's personal
history and a situational trigger so if
we use kamala as a rule here think of
her mutant gene as a lock mechanism her
ancestral nor dimension was the source
on the other side of that locked door
and the trigger key for her was the
bengal to compare this to another mutant
cyclops scott summers the lock mechanism
was his mutant gene the key was puberty
and the source of his awesome
ruby-colored optic blasts is actually a
dimension of pure energy to which
scott's eyes open small interdimensional
portals if you didn't know that about
cyclops that is actually how cyclops
fires those now how does this work for
wanda maximoff in the comics she is
known to be a mutant not sure yet in the
mcu but she has been called enhanced and
going by the dodc and ms marvel calling
characters enhanced to ended up being
mutants it is possible and i don't even
say likely that the mcu will go in that
direction for wanda and for her kids
billy and tommy who end up becoming the
mutants wiccan in speed in the comics i
think wanda's trigger was the trauma of
that stark warhead because she was first
able then to actively cast low-level
hexes to keep it from exploding the
source i think was catholic's dark magic
his curse that i think is what ordained
wanted to become the scarlet witch and
of course her mutant gene was the lock
mechanism that made this all connect now
wanda also had an additional trigger of
a boost of infinity stone radiation from
hydra and that's what i think elevated
her to the nexus being status because it
was in that moment that she saw her
future this might also explain why 838
billy and tommy don't have powers
because they have the genetic profile
and the source but not yet a trigger
they haven't really yet come of age or
been fully traumatized they almost did
and maybe they did in that moment the
616 scarlet witch scared the hell out of
them and maybe that's something for the
future of these kids but we didn't see
them yet in this moment have those
powers but if we compare them to billy
and tommy within the hex in one division
those were manifestations of wanda
empowered by the same trigger of wanda's
own trauma and her grief so really this
is just my best explanation of how
mutant kind will work in the mcu but i'm
gonna throw it to you what do you think
of this idea of three components being
necessary is it too confusing and if
anybody from marvel studios is watching
just wants to claim that as their idea
go for it follow me on instagram and
twitter boss follow me rockstar
subscribe to rockstars for more analysis
of everything you love thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
you